le rassemblement national est une
arnaque vous êtes les pires adversaires
des droits des femmes et d'ailleurs il
est intéressant Madame Le Pen que quand
en janvier 2022 le groupe parlementaire
de la France insoumise nupè a fait
adopter par la voix de clémentine Autin
à l'unanimité une résolution sur
l'endométriose vous n'étiez pas là vous
étiez aux abonnés absentes alors oui
vous êtes les pires adversaires des
droits des femmes Madame Le Pen c'est
vous qui disiez en 2012 le progrès pour
les femmes c'est de rester à la maison
c'est encore vous les eurodéputés ont
voté contre la réduction des écarts de
salaire femme homme encore vous dans
votre programme qui proposez de
supprimer le ministère de l'Égalité
femme homme et de voir les femmes
davantage program procréer je vais vous
dire vos amis ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire partout en Europe dont vous ne
vous cachez pas vous dites que vous
prenez comme modèle la Hongrie qui
oblige les femmes à écouter le cœur du
fétus avant de pouvoir avorter vos amis
en Pologne sont responsables de la mort
de six femmes dont Isabella Isabella qui
elle est morte d'une septicémie parce
qu'on lui a interdit d'avorter alors
qu'il y avait un problème pour sa santé
puisque madame pano a passé beaucoup de
temps à parler de mes amis vos amis à
vous madame Panau ils jettent le corps
des femmes derrière les pickup il
crachent dessus après les avoir violés
et les avoir démembré d'accord alors je
crois que vous devriez objectivement
faire preuve aujourd'hui de
modestie